in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion, from a first, on which we commemorate the holy and
devout Queen Tamra of Georgia, St. Tamra succeeded her father, George III, on the throne
of Georgia in 1184, 24 years of age, of great beauty and penetrating intelligence that
revealed a sincere and deep piety. She showed such aptitude in the governing of her people
on the evangelical path that she brought the kingdom of Georgia to its apogee. Directly
on her succession to the throne, having quashed a number of feudal revolts, she summoned
a council which restored a healthy ecclesiastical life and established a solid link in charity
between church and state. Thus, giving rebirth to the blessed times of Emperor Constantine,
pursuing the policies of her ancestor David the Builder towards the Persians and the Turkish
Celjaks, she herself rode at the head of her troops, and with the help of the Archangel
Michael whom her enemies could see at her side, achieved two brilliant victories at Siamkori
and Basiani. She thus extended the frontiers of her kingdom as far as the Caspian Sea, seized
Trebizond and Pontus, where she supported the creation of the Greek Orthodox Empire of Trebizond
after the taking of Constantinople by the Crusaders, and enthroned there her nephews, princes Alexis
and David Comnenus, who had been brought up in Georgia. Entire Muslim tribes then received
holy baptism. The Queen, so martial in her administration of the state, always pardoned those condemned
to death, and even abolished the death penalty. She gave abundant alms to the needy, visited
them in person, and had institutions built for their aid, to which she devoted a tenth
of the national income. She also founded many monasteries especially at Varsia in southern
Georgia, and after the taking of Jerusalem by Saladin, she brought back the precious cross
for the sum of 200,000 pieces of silver. The holy Queen Tamra gave her soul into God's
hands in peace on the 18th of January in 1213 after having confided her kingdom and her people
to his care. Through the prayers of our Holy Fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy
on us and save us.